in luhansk in eastern Ukraine Russian
colors and flags are everywhere this
billboard promotes a United Russia much
of the ethnic Russian population in this
war-torn area supports a referendum to
join Russia
we need Russia's protection says this
man speaking Russian
my generation was brought up in the
Soviet Union she says we need to unite
again but in zapparishia strong
Ukrainian Defiance toward Russia calling
the referendum illegitimate
absolutely a so-called referendum he
says is being forced from the outside
against the will of the people
the referendum he says is fake to show
occupied territories want to join Russia
fake or not many believe Russian
installed officials will declare all the
results in favor of joining Russia the
result those uh those referendums are
predetermined you know the majority of
the people in there will it'll be
reported that they support joining
Russia that is far from the truth Russia
is backing referendums in luhansk and
Donetsk and in zapparisia and Carson but
it is also here where Russian forces are
in control are trying to control eastern
Ukraine now Ukrainian forces to back
kharkiv but it is in these four
provinces where Russia appears to be
trying to consolidate both a military
grip and now a political grip that would
seamlessly connect Russia to Crimea and
in Russia's view it would turn this
fight in the region from an attack on
Ukraine to a defense of Russia President
Vladimir Putin has now threatened to use
nuclear weapons to defend what he deems
Russian territory and justify the
mobilization of more Russian forces he
has been losing
so now he is using this mobilization and
also the referenda Russia then can
pretend that any attempt to liberate
these Ukrainian territories would be a
direct attack on Russia itself the U.S
says Russia's actions will not stop the
fight inside those territories no
Russian claim to Annex territory can
take away Ukraine's right to defend its
own land in effect Washington and NATO
are calling Putin's Bluff but when
Russia says it will defend itself with
nuclear weapons it is a high stakes
Bluff for both sides Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto